- You're a dad, of
course, it's Phil Collins,
which is incredible to
us and normal for you.
(audience cheers and applauds)
But, it's just a really
cool thing for a musician.
But, what was your first concert,
other than obviously your dad's?
- The first concert, it was NSYNC.
- Oh my God! Did he hook you up?
- It was a hookup, but it was really like,
I just wanted to-
- It's a hookup!
You're in a picture with 'em!
- Yeah.
- [Kelly] Wait, I just saw the picture!
- Also, by the way, loved my outfit.
Also, the butterfly clip, I
just, I loved all their outfits.
I just, everything about it.
- They were babies! That's one
of their first tours, maybe.
- You know what was even crazier?
Is, you know who opened for them
that no one knew who she was?
Britney Spears.
- What?
- Literally-
- Your dad
totally hooked you up.
- Honest, he hooked up
the opening act too.
I remember sitting in the
audience and they were like,
"Oh, and please welcome the
opening act: Brittney Spears."
And everyone's like, "Who is, what?
Who is Brittany Spears?"
- Oh my!
- And she came on and did
"Hit Me Baby One More Time"
and everyone's like, "Wow, she's good!
She's good!"
- She's gonna make it!
- She's gonna do something.
- It was wild, then cut to-